l'usiné mécanique avant gardes avant
garde en russe produit des antimissiles
pour les célèbres systèmes de défense
antiaérienne s-300 et s-400 triumph la
plupart du site dizaine d'ateliers son
sucre est au top secret mais à
l'occasion de ses 80 ans l'usi nous a
laissés jetter un coup d'oeil dans son
enceinte
[Musique]
nous sommes dans l'atelier
d'installations électriques
ici le système nerveux une partie
essentielle de l'antimissile qui assure
son efficacité est mise en place cette
tâche ne peut pas à toujours être
confiée à robot des ouvrières le fond
plus rapidement et plus précisément
qu'un appareil automatique
[Musique]
c'est le sens des 100 des ateliers de
l'avant garde l'atelier de l'assemblage
où se déroule l'étape finale de la
production dû s 400 pendant l'époque
soviétique cette partie de lusine fut
tellement secrète qu'il n'existe aucune
photo de ses locaux datant de cette
période même aujourd'hui les
journalistes étrangers n'y sont pas
admis
[Musique]
de 50000 personnes sont impliquées dans
la création du produit le vol d'un
missile dure vingt secondes et sa
construction prend 20 mois
s 400 ont été achetés par la turquie
l'inde ou encore la chine c'est complexe
de défense aérienne protège également
moscou et d'autres régions russes
avant-garde s'attend à une hausse de
production est infirme peaufiner ses
technologies dans la perspective d'une
production écologique au maximum et
selon le slogan de lusine avant-garde ne
rate jamais sa cible